et deux ans après le début de cette
crise sanitaire ils estiment que leurs
conditions de travail ne se sont pas
améliorées et demandent une meilleure
reconnaissance de leur métier chez les
travailleurs dits essentiels manifestent
cet après midi une mobilisation des
caissiers des livreurs ou encore des
femmes de ménage à l'appel de la cfdt on
retrouve en direct de la marche
parisienne notre reporter le cas légers
l'appel à manifester at il été entendu
lucas
oui absolument et nous approchons du
point final de cette manifestation la
place cambronne qui se trouve à quelques
mètres devant nous ces manifestants sont
venus nombreux ici nous sommes sur le
boulevard de grenelle vous pouvez voir
sur ces images de stéphane puccini
qu'ils brandissent leurs drapeaux cfdt
des travailleurs essentiel c'est à dire
des gens qui ont continué de travailler
sur site pendant le confinement de
deville 20 des personnes de la grande
distribution de la sécurité de la
propreté de l'aide à la personne des
gens qui ont été applaudis parfois à 20h
au balcon seulement voilà ils estiment
que les salaires dans leur milieu
reste très bas je vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'ils nous ont dit
je suis ouvrier dans un abattoir de porc
ce qui nous trotte scandalise
aujourd'hui c'est que le travailleur est
essentielle on est plus devenu essentiel
mais on a vu l'augmentation du smig en
octobre de 2 2% on a demandé à nos
employeurs de venir à la table des
négociations pour revaloriser nos
salaires on est là aujourd'hui parce que
pendant le covin on a travaillé comme
des fous et qui a pas eu de
reconnaissance au niveau des salaires
donc ça fait deux ans que ça dure donc
on est tous là ce matin les monoprix
pour dire que la nana u0022
d'augmentation générale il n'est pas
question c'est à dire qu'on est là même
pourcentage pas ce qui est important
c'est l'hérault dollarisation de salaire
des gens pour tous nos métiers dits
essentiels s'est dit jose qui a plus
important et une aux conditions de
travail qui sont déplorables depuis déjà
très longtemps et surtout depuis deux
ans
vous l'avez entendu ils veulent
maintenant des négociations de branche
pour revaloriser les salaires il estime
aussi que certaines des entreprises pour
lesquelles ils ont travaillé se sont
enrichis de pendant la crise des
entreprises qui ont aussi pour certaines
bénéficier d' acte de l'état ils veulent
désormais que ses bénéfices reviennent
pour partie aux salariés alors même que
l'inflation suscite de grandes
inquiétudes
[Musique]